we've been dating for like three months
it's going well yeah
found him on tinder big off month well I
should tell the story though yeah you
Phyllis I'm not staying for years just
in the industry we had what was known as
a nodding relationship I ended up
jumping on stage with him uninvited
uninvited which I kind of anyway uh I
got over yeah I had a song called don't
make me wait and I sent it to sting and
in in the midst of doing this verse and
realize that we really enjoy making
music together so from the first moment
we decided to work together people were
so surprised what on earth are you two
doing together we like that because
because we like surprised and I think
when people hear what we've done on the
record they'll be surprised again cuz we
were it's it's not just a surprise when
you think about it we both love reggae
music
we both have ridiculous names and we
actually like each other believe it or
not a nightmare
I wrote Roxanne in Paris in 1976 I
believe now it's become a drinking song
in American universities where kids have
of shots and every time I say the word
rocks and they take a shot really and
after like a verse so they're completely
out of their minds I'm not particularly
proud of that it's just an interesting
phenomena how a song can have more than
one use please don't do that at home
there was Americans how we might when I
was much younger my hair was really
really light and shaggy so I was this
really skinny guy with these really big
knees and I just look really awkward and
they called me shaggy if you shag it off
but then I came to England after
Carolina and I got picked up at the
airport
at Heathrow and oak Carolina came on and
the car drivers like I can't believe
they're playing a record
from a bloke called shaggy and I'm like
so I asked the record company personally
look or say what what's wrong with that
Oh shaggy check means something else
over here and then she explained it to
me and I was like oh that's my new
reason yeah I like something I don't
think Alan of his British but I always
have I'll tell you what it will nappy
pie is that British his banoffee pie
British no I've never heard of it you
know like banoffee pie is so why you're
looking at me like you would is that I
go to his house in New York and he's
like shaggy come for breakfast what is
he making English breakfast full English
breakfast for now would you give me
brown sauce he puts brown sauce and
everything he put it on the bread he put
it on the cake it's brown sauce but
everything what's with the brown sauce
bro I'm actually from war's end and I
was born literally within within yards
of the river so you couldn't get more
Geordi that than me really I've lost my
accent largely until I get angry and
when I get angry something comes out
that sounds very threatening they have
seen me angry my nickname for him is
Mother Teresa when [ __ ] pisses it off
you know it has this calm Oh gentlemen
let's just sit down and think about it
can I see you breaks up it just wait
it's a young relationship
yeah today for a couple hours all you've
been dating for like three months it's
going well yeah Farnham on tinder
[Laughter]